qu'est ce que vous faites bien la télé
écouter ce qu'il a écrit gainsbourg je
marquais promptement un penchant très
nette pour le dessin mais la spontanéité
de mes croquis et la fraîcheur naïve de
mes aquarelles furent aussitôt calmé par
les pédagogues qui n'avait que faire de
mes ballons cubique de mes lapins à
damier cochon bleus et autres fantasmes
embryonnaire et comme il me fallait me
soumettre je me venge à la piscine ou
jeu lâchait près d'eux des bulls irisé
qui remontait en bouillonnant à la
surface avant d'éclater à l'air pur
en libérant leur gaz contestataires
c'est bien non ouais ouais super porte
est scellée qui il pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux